hé les gars venez on est tranquille on
m'a suffisamment dans merde dans notre
vie a peut-être essayons de nous amuser
et d'être un peu en paix avec nous quoi
j'ai ce corps là en ce moment et
j'essaie de vivre avec et c'est aussi en
passant par ces photos là que j'arrive à
m'estimer un peu j insistais vraiment
sur le fait de jeu ne veut pas de
retouches je veux pas parce que c'est un
truc que je sers pour moi il s'avère que
je les postés sur les réseaux parce que
je me suis trouvée jolie et que et que
je me suis dit ah bah tiens en fait
c'est vraiment un corps de femme et
c'est encore que je trouve beau j'ai vu
que ça a pu aider des gens s dirais moi
aussi j'en ai de le faire ou et moi
aussi
genre il met une jupe ou j'en sais rien
[Musique]
3 que les grimaces ça marche bien parce
que bas parce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on voit pas on fait avec nos potes ou
tout seul chez nous et qu'on montre pas
parce qu'il faut pas le montrer parce
qu'il faut pas être moche et faut pas
faire des trucs comme ça quoi non c'est
aussi pour contrer ce truc de deux très
jolis de poser comme ça machin belge
envie de faire gens justement entre
comme la belle que je trouve ça
tellement coup s'est aussi d'une
certaine manière détournée un vrai
problème de société qui est de il faut
être jolie il faut être souvent
maquillées il ne faut pas être ou s'il
faut pas avoir de taches de rousseur il
faut pas urgence à rien et que justement
en fait non on est tous humains on va
tous aux toilettes on met tous de nos
doigts dans le nez fin c'est humain il
ya aucun mal à ça beaucoup de maquillage
beaucoup de fonds magnifique des photos
parfaites un petit déjeuner où tu mets
les myrtilles les bananes et tout ça
alors que personne ne fait ça il y avait
ce truc qui me dérangeait pas ce que
l'image de la femme était représenté par
quelque chose qui ne me semble pas tout
à fait juste
il ya beaucoup d'ados d'adolescents qui
s'identifient à ces femmes là dans ce
truc du culte du parfait et c'est là où
je pense qu'il ya un vrai danger parce
que on dit qu instagram est interdit au
moins de 13 ans mais en fait si j'en
suis sûr qu'il ya plein d'ados bain de
jeunes enfants qui vont là dessus et qui
disent ah je veux trop être comme ça je
trouve ressembler à ça et qu'ils
rentrent dans un genre de système de
d'un truc qui selon moi est pas bon quoi